here are some beautiful words  effervescence bubbles in a liquid he  write a longing for a home you can't  return to or that never was ephemeral  lasting for a very short time  incandescent light produced by high  temperatures limerence the state of  being infatuated with another person  some nebulous a person who sleepwalks  sonorous an imposing ly deep and full  sound  mellifluous a sound that is sweet and  smooth pleasing to hear Aurora dawn  phosphenes  the light and colors produced by rubbing  your eyes epic a particular period of  time in history or a person's life  epiphany a moment of sudden revelation  defenestration the act of throwing  someone out of a window  petrichor the pleasant earthy smell  after rain luminescence light produced  by chemical electrical or physiological  means which words do you think are  beautiful